the main antagonist of the dceu's
justice league is steppenwolf a
dishonored general from apocalypse who
once failed to conquer earth and
as a punishment was banished he's back
in shinier than ever in the epic snyder
cut
but what's his deal anyway here's the
untold truth of steppenwolf
despite boasting such a major big screen
appearance steppenwolf has remained
somewhat unknown to the general public
which is a shame given his rich history
in the source material steppenwolf first
entered the dc
scene in 1972 in the pages of jack
kirby's new gods
two years after the debut of his lord
and master darkseid despite not being in
charge of apocalypse steppenwolf has
proven important enough to survive
multiple retcons and has famously
appeared in two different forms on the
big screen
or at least he will if the snyder cut
ever hits theaters
at last you called me home
wait a minute isn't jack kirby a marvel
guy what's he doing moonlighting over at
dc
inventing evil gods fair question kirby
felt a bit under-appreciated at marvel
what with stan lee's increasing
celebrity
in an attempt to step out from his media
savvy partner's shadow he struck out on
his own signing an exclusive three-year
deal to work his kirby magic for the
rival publisher
eager to surpass lee kirby wanted to go
big with his dc debut he envisioned a
massive expansion of the dc
universe via three interconnected series
that would introduce expansive science
fiction worlds and technologies
as well as elements of popular pulp
genres of the time like space opera to
the world of batman and superman
kirby named this project 4th wall and
with it he hoped to tell stories with
existential stakes on a galactic level
steppenwolf and darkseid were born of
this grandiose aspiration
and to be honest we're lucky they're
still around because kirby's master plan
kind of felt flat for dc readers
the fourth world series was quickly and
unceremoniously cancelled due to lack of
sales
kirby bid dc ado and went back to marvel
for a bit before venturing forth into
the wild world of indie comics
kirby did come back to dc during the
reagan administration to see to his
destructive creations
he apparently wanted to kill them all
off definitively but dc had attachment
issues even then and a standing policy
of denying the finality of death
as a result steppenwolf and the other
new gods got to stick around in various
conflicting incarnations long after
their creator's time with them was done
steppenwolf and darkseid along with the
other new gods have been perhaps the
most enduring products of this brief
sojourn for kirby across town
the real world origin story of these
characters goes a long way in explaining
their difficult birth into dc
and the epic retconning that took place
for decades thereafter
steppenwolf is one of the new gods a
race of beings who reside on the twin
planets of apocalypse and new genesis
created by jack kirby in the 70s during
kirby's brief but passionate affair with
rival comic shop dc
there's not much moral complexity in new
gods in the fourth world stories new
genesis is good apocalypse is bad
new genesis is a futuristic utopia at
peace with itself and brimming with
astonishing
technology it basically looks like the
future we were promised in the 1950s
apocalypse meanwhile looks more like the
future we actually got
other apocalyptian new gods include such
fascistic resonance as dark side and
granny goodness
and like most godly pantheons all of
these characters have strange and
twisted familial relationships
the authoritarian ruler of apocalypse
known as darkseid is the son of the new
gods yuga khan and hegra
while little is known of yuga khan's
family hegra has one known blood
relative of note and that's steppenwolf
yes this means that steppenwolf is
darkseid's uncle
however given that darkseid is currently
the most powerful new god alive
steppenwolf would be a fool to try and
take the throne from him despite being
his elder then again steppenwolf seems
to like his current position as
commander of apocalypse's military since
it lets him lead his forces into bloody
battle
he's been at it since the reign of yuga
khan and hegrup and since failure on
apocalypse is usually rewarded with
death
it's safe to say steppenwolf must be
pretty good at what he does
apocalypse is one of the most
technologically advanced planets in the
dc universe and it likewise houses one
of the most powerful militaries
the only force that keeps the world in
check and protects the rest of creation
is its antithesis new genesis
since the planets are essentially oil
and water you might assume they would
wage an eternal war with one another
once upon a time they did and it was all
steppenwolf's fault
ever since darkseid was born he schemed
against anyone who stood in his way to
claim the throne of apocalypse this
included his parents his older brother
drax and even his uncle steppenwolf
while drax was easy enough to eliminate
steppenwolf took a little more finesse
so darkseid convinced him to participate
in the popular apocalyptian pastime of
hunting down and killing new genocinians
one of steppenwolf's targets was the
leader of new genesis
i father isaiah but isaiah's wife avia
sacrificed herself to save him
following this isaiah slew steppenwolf
in revenge and thus the war between new
genesis and apocalypse
was started of course darkseid
eventually resurrected steppenwolf and
put him in charge of the military of
apocalypse because
you know comics when jack kirby set
about to create his new gods he probably
didn't realize just how big a role these
godly beans would come to play in the
greater dc
universe if he did he might not have
killed off so many of the major players
so fast
in fact the vast majority of
steppenwolf's appearances in jack kirby
penned works happen in flashback
sequences
his new gods number seven debut wherein
steppenwolf is temporarily killed was
itself a flashback story though the
death obviously didn't take the
flashback frame of new gods number seven
means that steppenwolf was functionally
dead upon arrival in the dc universe
kirby's 1985 mini-series super powers
brought steppenwolf back
though this limited run was published as
a toy tie-in for kenner toys and isn't
considered canon
it wasn't until dc published who's who
the definitive directory of the dc
universe that steppenwolf's entry
clarified it was indeed apocalyptian
technology administered by his nephew
darkseid that brought him back to the
world of the living
the monstrous being known as doomsday is
known for being unstoppable but
steppenwolf somehow survived an
encounter with this creature long before
superman was even born
even more impressive is that ever the
loyal uncle he saved darkseid from an
early grave in the process
darkseid's fight with doomsday began
thousands of years ago after the lord of
apocalypse ran afoul of krypton's
greatest monster and a stroke of
cosmically bad luck
doomsday hurtled himself into the way
like the organic spiky meteor he is and
he tore through darkseid's forces
even darkseid almost fell before
doomsday's unstoppable onslaught but
darkseid was rescued at the last minute
by steppenwolf however since darkseid's
word is law and it might be embarrassing
to acknowledge such a massive near
defeat
he and steppenwolf agreed to never speak
about this rescue ever again
in the dc universe steppenwolf is part
of ancient history and it's not entirely
clear if kirby ever expected him to play
such an active role in the present
that changed a bit as the new gods
became increasingly integrated with
other stories
dc's new 52 initiative brought change to
just about every corner of the dc
universe and despite steppenwolf's
god-like abilities he wasn't immune
among many many other things the new 52
introduced a fresh version of earth 2 to
the dc multiverse
it's there that steppenwolf first staged
a massive invasion of the blue planet
with a seating board of parademons
the ensuing battle results in some
pretty significant deaths on the hero
side but only the inferior earth 2
versions
and by the end steppenwolf decides to
cool his heels in that universe
dodging a 300 million dollar bounty on
his head long story short he's
ultimately killed by bizarro before
later being
resurrected yet again if you think the
difference between snyder steppenwolf
and the one in the 2017 version of
justice league is noticeable
while his comic book design has been all
over the place and the iconic horned
helmet he now wears is a relatively
recent addition
when steppenwolf first appeared for
instance his look could best be
described as medieval punk
with lime green skin green armor and
belts a green cape and a pointy green
hat
that couldn't decide if it belonged to a
wizard or pirate this is the design that
also made it to the dc animated universe
in shows such as superman the animated
series
parademons attack
however for a time comics abandoned this
classic look for one featuring an orange
red getup with spikes and a giant axe
connected to his back
this was all part of the aforementioned
superpowers kenner toys tie-in
the design went on to appear in mr
miracle comics and beyond and while
subsequent dc cartoons returned
steppenwolf to his original green
threads the electro axe became a
mainstay of his armory
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
dc comics are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one